in Hong Kong preparations are underway
to wake up The territory's Nightlife
after a Hiatus due to covid-19 measures
live entertainment will return to bars
and restaurants
finally my band is Happy me itself as a
musician that finally we get back I know
it's long overdue under the new
restrictions performance will be
required to complete two PCR tests a
week and Rapid tests before entering
venues the government helps to allow
citizens to resume their normal lives
with their infection risk under control
groups of up to 12 are now permitted and
dancing at clubs is also allowed the
government hopes these changes will help
boost Hong Kong's struggling economy a
lot of the sectors that we very much
rely on for boosting our growth such as
tourism for example exports are really
in the doldrums because of the covered
restrictions bar owner John primer says
his business took a hit during Hong
Kong's strict 19 measures and had to
suspend operations still he says he's
optimistic yeah I I think the music
scene's going to come back very strong
and a lot of guys during covert a lot of
the guys wrote music and have recorded
it so they've got a lot of new stuff
they want to showcase Hong Kong's theme
parks once a popular attraction for
domestic and international visitors are
also set to benefit from the policy
change the new protocol will allow
visitors to dine in at theme parks and
while it will take much more to
rejuvenate Hong Kong's tourism and
entertainment sectors many say any
relaxation in covert rules will bring
much needed relief Ocean Park says it's
preparing for more visitors to return
Hong Kong has more measures in place
than most cities in Asia there are no
quarantine requirements but mask
mandates remain and travelers must do
three PCR tests within a week of
arriving experts say the health
situation is under control but there are
other factors at play as Beijing pursues
a strict zero covid-19 strategy Hong
Kong government is more cautious and of
course they have to look after the
interest for the uh you know the the
central government uh in in Maine and
China as well as more restrictions are
eased many say allowing a bit more fun
might just be what Hong Kong's people
and its economy needs
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong